foreign
[Music]
ews today you can expect some updates on
the sequels of the Joker and the Batman
as well as on the cast of Deadpool 3 and
Captain America 4. animation fans can
look forward to short films about
Spider-Man and Pixar's Up and lovers of
tough action will find what they're
looking for with news about the John
Wick franchise have fun watching
prepare yourselves to shed some tears
again because Pixar has a new up short
film coming Carl state will be screened
in theaters before the new Pixar film
Elemental and revolves around the
Beloved old man whose story with his
first great love already captured our
hearts in 2009. Carl's date follows Carl
Fredrickson as he prepares for his first
date since the death of his wife Ellie
directed and scripted by Bob Peterson
the short film is said to be deeply
touching but also hilarious and the
perfect introduction for Elemental
Peterson explained that Carl's date is
the final chapter in the up story this
is due in part to the fact that Carl's
voice actor Ed Asner has to weigh
shortly after the short film was shot
originally Carl state was supposed to
premiere on Disney plus along with the
series Doug days but it was later
dropped from the schedule now it's clear
why the short film merits a debut on the
big screen Carl's date will Premiere in
theaters on June 16 2023 along with
elemental
so far 2019's Joker is the most
successful R-rated film of all time box
office takings of more than one billion
dollars the story of the mentally ill
Outsider Arthur Fleck who becomes
increasingly insane due to a number of
blows by Fate is to be continued next
year this week there was again news
about the film detached from the DC
Universe which just like the Batman is
part of the so-called elseworlds the
news is not so much about Joaquin
Phoenix as Arthur Fleck but about his
co-star Lady Gaga will play the second
starring role in Sugar 2 there had not
been any pictures of her in full costume
so far which is why the leaked images
from the set made massive ways the
Harley Quinn actress can be seen on set
with corresponding makeup and a red
blazer the diamond pattern that can be
seen on her top her blazer and her
thighs is striking and will apparently
play a big role in the look of the main
character likewise leaked from the set
was a copy of the Gotham examiner on
which the Love Story between Joker and
Harley is fittingly described as crazy
of Love last but not least there is a
third piece of news from the shooting
currently taking place in New York City
on the posters of several actors
demonstrating there are references to
Harvey Dent AKA Two-Face which is why
the official announcement of his
character should also only be a matter
of time filming on Joker 2 Folia 2 is
expected to last a few more months as it
only kicked off in March of 2023 then
fans will finally be able to watch the
end result in cinemas on October 4th
2024.
many fans can hardly wait for the
release of Deadpool 3. after the big
surprise that Hugh Jackman is part of
the project as Wolverine there are now
further additions to the cast the first
one is set to be succession actor
Matthew McFadden the 48 year old has not
yet been given a role in the MCU which
is why we can only make speculations
about his exact role in the HBO series
he plays fan favorite Tom wamsganz since
the final season is currently running
McFadden will certainly have time for a
larger role in Deadpool 3. according to
many Hollywood magazines Owen Wilson is
expected to appear as Mobius and Mobius
Wilson last played the role of the agent
of the time variants Authority TBA for
short in the Loki series however
possibly his biggest job to date awaits
him with the two main characters
Deadpool and Wolverine after all the
latter is particularly known for
wreaking havoc it is not yet 100 sure
whether Wilson will really play his part
again but Insider Jeff Snyder has proven
to be a reliable source in the past we
will probably first learn more about the
future of agent Mobius in season 2 of
the Loki series which according to
Wilson is scheduled for the end of the
summer or early fall Deadpool 3 will be
released in theaters on November 8 2024.
Warner Brothers is currently in the
process of assembling the cast for the
Batman 2 which is set to hit theaters in
late 2025. Robert Pattinson is of course
back as the Batman though fans are
eagerly awaiting the reveal of the new
villain according to deadline that
villain could be Clayface Clayface is a
DC villain who shows up in two versions
in the comics Burien one Matthew Hagan
is a treasure hunter who gains the
ability to manipulate his physical
features after interacting with the
radioactive pool variate 2 basil baz
Carlo is an actor who once played a
villain named Clayface and now seeks
revenge on those involved in a Movie
remake in the upcoming film we will also
be able to enjoy a reunion with Alfred
once again played by Amy circus fans are
naturally curious as to what extent Paul
Dano will be featured as the Riddler
along with Colin Farrell as the penguin
the latter is set to star in his own HBO
Max Series in addition there are still
rumors about the Joker who already
appeared in a cut scene in the Batman
played by Barry kyogan while it's not
known yet who will play Clayface fans
are looking forward to a serious and
down-to-earth take on the villain in
this dark film Universe director Matt
Reeves has hinted that much of his story
will be available ahead of the film's
release on HBO Max making fans very
excited to find out where and how the
character will come to life the most
exciting appearance would then certainly
occur on October 3rd 2025 when the
Batman part 2 releases in movie theaters
John Wick chapter 4 has been running in
cinemas since last week following the
release all sorts of news were published
by those responsible many of which also
addressed the future of the franchise
last Sunday film producer Joseph Drake
talked about what awaits fans after John
Wick 4. according to Drake they are not
ready to move on from Keanu Reeves just
yet he said there are several
possibilities as to how to proceed now
at least one appearance by Reeves in an
upcoming John Wick spin-off has been
confirmed for quite some time he is
expected to return in front of the
camera in the feature film ballerina
filming of the spin-off series the
Continental which revolves around the
former life of Hotel manager Winston is
also said to be almost done almost
nothing has yet been heard about Keanu
Reeves potential involvement since the
series has set many years before the
current film series an appearance is
rather unmikely the Continental is
scheduled for this fall according to
Drake so to what extent can the
franchise keep Keanu around besides the
short appearance that has been confirmed
terms so far when it comes to director
Chaz tohelski he could easily imagine a
John Wick 5. he affirmed in an interview
with Entertainment Weekly that he loves
the film series but currently sees no
good reason to produce another sequel
however he could not rule out the
possibility either of him and Keanu
meeting in a bar five months from now
and coming to the decision to make a
fifth installment after all a third
person who has come forward in the past
few days as producer Erica Lee she holds
out the prospect of announcing a new
film in the John Wick Universe in the
next two months as there is a lot of
work going on behind the scenes as we
speak she also expressed optimism about
a fifth John Wick and the second
ballerina film will knows in charge
possibly develop a film based on the
post-credits scene from part 4 at least
Kane actor Donnie Yen is upbeat about
reprising his role in an interview with
variety we remain excited to see what
other news we can look forward to in the
coming weeks
Sony pictures animation and Sony
Pictures imageworks have jointly
announced a short film titled the spider
within it is scheduled for release in
June and will be related to the upcoming
Spider-Man across the spider-verse the
story revolves around Miles Morales a
teenager and superhero who deals with
those multiple roles in life including
being a student and a friend the short
film depicts how miles learns after
having a panic attack that asking for
help is just as courageous as saving the
city from Evil the spider within is part
of Sony pictures animation and Sony
Pictures imageworks newly launched lens
mentorship program it aims to give
people from underrepresented groups
leadership experience in filmmaking we
can't wait to see the results the
expectations for such a popular
franchise are bound to be huge the
feature film Spider-Man across the
spider-verse will be released on June
2nd 2023.
it feels like a lifetime ago that the
Hulk was portrayed by Edward Norton and
not by current actor and Fan Favorite
Mark Ruffalo the last time the fight
club star was seen in the role of the
Green Giant was in 2008. in addition to
Norton as Bruce Banner Liv Tyler was
also seen as his girlfriend Betty Ross
who played the biggest role in The
Incredible Hulk alongside the villain
Abomination now according to current
reports she might return to the MCU in
the upcoming Captain America new world
order that makes perfect sense given
that Betty Ross is as the name suggests
the daughter of the new U.S president
Thaddeus Ross who will be played by none
other than Indiana Jones star Harrison
Ford moreover there were first pictures
from the set of Captain America 4 New
World Order with main actor Anthony
Mackey last week although he cannot be
seen in his full costume but only in his
everyday clothes as the captain updates
from the set are of course always
appreciated shooting for Captain America
4 started just a few days ago so there
will be plenty of opportunities to catch
up on more news about the new captain
before the movie releases on May 3rd
2024.
we hope you enjoyed this week's news if
you feel the urge to watch even more
content we suggest to check out our new
movie preview for Godzilla vs Kong 2.
there you can find all the latest info
and theories on the sequel thanks for
watching and see you next week for more
Weekly News
[Music]
thank you